okay go live
okay for people who are joining this
live stream we are doing
some incremental language development
design discussion
and uh looks like we have a simple
agenda but that's those are always the
ones that turn out to be the most
complicated
okay let's start off with this first one
date object granularity and default time
zone
so this is spawned by a question you had
over the weekend about
why if i do date object of 2002 or some
year granularity why is there a time
zone showing up by default
and so what we discussed a little bit
jose and i is that
there's a couple of ways to potentially
address that and
one of them that we discussed in the
past is saying there's a certain
granularity threshold
already within the system where if you
have different time zones we
still consider the dates equal today
with a time zone of zero is considered
the same day and still equal to today
with a time zone of minus five or plus
five
and so what we were thinking is we can
what about minus 18 or minus 22 or
something
yeah so right now the threshold we have
with that
is that there is an internal switch we
basically have for doing
comparisons that say if the granularity
is at least
this then we're basically time zone
agnostic it doesn't matter what your
time zone is
we will do the comparison looking at the
date part and once you
factor in an hour or something smaller
than that then we need to account for
time zone but what we had been doing at
least up until we started playing around
with this
yesterday was saying that your default
dollar time zone gets inserted in the
date object even if we're not
looking at it for some granularities
right which is a bad thing because that
means that
you know um you know
the um i don't know
you're you're putting a time zone into
the
you know into some historical year it
just doesn't make any sense and you end
up concluding
you know yeah go ahead so
what do we think we want to have happen
so as far as jose and i were talking
about it there's sort of
two different paths one would be to say
we have some granularity at which we
switch
between saying a time zone should be
included
and a time zone shouldn't and we can
populate that
with time zone is none for example
so that you know if we need to resolve
it
a time zone for a specific operation
that needs an instant we already have a
precedence of using dollar time zone
when we need to
but if you're in iceland and generate
the date
2002 and i'm in alaska and generated the
expert
form will be the same so that's sort of
what this
this example here is what we tried
putting in prototype
just to play around is if we change
basically have that switch at the day
granularity
is the coarsest granularity where we
leave the time zone as none
and once you have an hour or smaller we
need to insert the time zone
so that we know what you're referring to
okay
so right yeah i mean that makes sense to
me yeah yeah
nothing down to days there's no time
zone
and you can still explicitly set it if
for some reason you need to
you know if i explicitly say time zone
goes to time zone
in a day granular object we will insert
that time zone because you said to but
otherwise we would have the default b
that it's none okay are you going to are
you going to have a settable parameter
for that or not
i don't think you need to because i
think it's pretty obvious that you do
not want a time zone
above granularity of days right and it
corresponds to the fact that when we
typeset these
if it's day or larger we don't typeset
the time zone even if it's there
well there may be computations in which
this is needed imagine somebody
worrying about when to celebrate new
year
depending on location etc so they may
want to specify
what they mean what they mean by year
with a time zone
sorry say it again new year what new
year's yes
so that's some exact moment today
january 1st
shouldn't they oh i see what you're
saying you're saying
if it matters when uh something changes
from one year to another because you are
worrying about your celebration of
of new year then you may need that
information in the date object
so the original motivation and that's
why the
the time zone has been there for years
is is to specify
uniquely the period corresponding to
each date object
but it's true what you are saying that
if you have dates
in in data or in associations etc
then having the time zone may be
problematic
okay so wait a minute if i want to get
the very beginning of the year 2002
how do i do it
no system well that's a separate
question
so they they don't think it is a
separate question because i think that
that
if i give this that's the year right so
how do i get the very beginning of that
year the moment at which that year
begins
if you said date object of percent
or yeah date objective percent comma
instant would turn it into an instant
and our precedence is always that when
you
instantiate a data object it goes to its
beginning instant okay and that's
picking up a time zone for dot from
dollar time zone
yep okay but if i had given a time zone
here
if i'd said time zone
10 or something then this instant
would have been okay so it seems fine
yeah right so so it's totally fine to
change our default so
what i was saying is that sometimes the
knowledge of the time zone is needed
even when the granularity is above a day
i i think so give me the example again
yeah so imagine somebody is trying to
find whether
we have changed or not to a different
year
and and it depends on the location
are people in japan already in the new
year or not
thinking
but that requires going to an instant
having a year granularity
[Music]
so you're saying if i say
um
let's say 2021
okay and then i say now less than that
oh i can't do that how do i do that it's
because it's overlapping
and so comparisons here will look and
say 2021 is a
horse granularity object if that was you
know
20. but notice here this gregorian minus
four craziness
going on here that's type setting yes
i i don't know do you know nick why this
doesn't accept
uh it's something to do with the message
forms
no i understand that but why is it even
saying minus four what i thought you
said you just changed this to not have
gone
out to not have a time zone when it's
when it's a
non you know when it's a year level
granularity date
well there yeah so there's two
approaches for that sorry index kernel
so the
next change yeah and there's two
approaches for that
one would be to explicitly ha say time
zone is none
or the other would be to basically omit
the parameter in the input form
i would prefer to omit the parameter and
the same with
calendar type i'm guessing that
you know if you don't specif if it's a
non-gregorian date we'll have the
calendar type in there but if it's a
gregorian date
it doesn't need to have gregorian
carried around in it
i think so i think drop gregorian i mean
that's the default
yeah i can't see why you would include
gregorian i think it's just
unnecessary fluff that's gonna you know
yeah i don't see it
okay so this in this case now the time
zone here
this is going to be you say
why is it still minus four well maybe i
just have the wrong build
yeah we just put it in yesterday's with
me okay
yeah that's older okay yeah i'm way old
gosh why do i have such an honor okay
we got some comments on the live stream
here from uh
p winkler complaining that
this is not the correct result
that is true part of that is
the heuristic date parser is complicated
and is not well set up for parsing time
zones
so we don't have a date format in there
so it
there there are improvements we're
making to handle cases like that
and 12.3 has a lot of improvements in
date string processing but the automatic
time zone parser is complicated and has
a what
what what i don't even know what this
means does the z represent sulu time or
something
so that's the standard iso
8601 notation for date time that
includes
z for gmt
okay so the complaint is that uh
it's giving it back in your local time
zone with the time
unchanged so it should either be
detecting that it is gmt and giving yeah
i understand so that's
the that's a bug yeah um
time zone is ignored and dates and
oh i see they told you john's the wrong
result yes we agree it's a bug
um from date strings also ignoring time
zone
even if i tell it time zone zero
that seemed to work oh it's ignoring it
in the past but it is
i'm able to overlay force overlay that
time zone
yeah surely this can't be that hard to
fix
i mean isn't this a specific case for
the iso specification
yeah it is a specific case and we have
improvements for specific
formula or for specific date formats but
for
general heuristic days pricing it's more
complicated because there are lots of
different
time zone notations we can improve it
for
specific date formats and we're working
on
extending that and improving performance
across the board we've picked up a
decent bit of speed up for 12-3 but
every extra bit of complication we add
in particularly the heuristic parser has
big performance hits potentially
right so
yeah right but i agree by the way this
this is the correct result here
i mean the type setting is ugly but the
result is correct
if it's overlapping you cannot resolve
it right
yeah that follows our general interval
comparison algorithms fair enough
um
let's see
yeah come on from eli about the the
beginning of the new year is obviously a
dynamic thing around the world
and even we now have right is geo what
is it called geo orientation data right
what should i put in here some so
you can say i don't know some date and
then
uh day duration something
so that i mean it runs in the type
setting but if you don't put form
or date direct date duration access i
actually i'm going to i'm going to try
something i'm just curious
date object okay so now if i say day
duration for a year what's it going to
do
oh i have no idea i guess it will choose
the first day
okay so if i decide yeah
it doesn't average or anything like that
does it know the future it has some
predictions
but they are very i mean
yeah it has some some general trend in
the sense
of um there is a parabolic
general trend oh wow look at that
yeah so the variations are in the
ordinary of milliseconds if you say they
duration day duration excess
then you get uh yeah is that because it
wasn't measured much in the early part
of the century
no because these these values are were
measured
very precisely since the 60s or 50s with
the atomic clocks before
there were just some indications
and so the the data is less precise
and if we go thousands of years there is
just a parabolic trend
which is caused by what by the slowing
down of the rotation of the earth
why is it parabolic why isn't it linear
um well
so the yes the duration of the day is
linear
the parabolic trend is the difference um
between atomic time and youth and solar
um
sorry universal time yes i was thinking
of something that's different
yeah this is linear the day duration is
linear is increasing
linearly why is this why is this period
one i think it's period one oscillation
here i'm just curious
uh there are several periods here um
some related to the moon
some related to the day um
yeah it's i mean the in the examples in
the
the orientation data page there are
nicer graphs
and applications i think
yeah so that's that is getting shorter
exactly the data in recent years it's
getting shorter but
this is just some sort of local effect
the parabolic trend is is uh
sorry the the global trend is is linear
increasing i think there is a graph for
it
and you still expect us to get as much
work done
[Laughter]
there's not as many seconds in the day
yeah right
interesting okay yeah so that's how the
rotation of the the axis of rotation is
moving
with respect to geographic north
hmm
well interesting stuff okay uh all right
is there anything more to say about this
um
so just to confirm so do agree
on removing the output
uh the third and fourth arguments in
output yes i do
in the case where that where they are
default gregorian and none
okay um
sandra just put this in the live stream
what happened here
oh terrible terrible and it's
polar plot
polar plots doesn't seem to have so so
the claim would be if i did list plot
here
i see that nice error bars
but the polar plot doesn't know that
it's supposed to give
what the heck should it give exactly i'm
thinking about that
[Music]
the polar plot is giving um
these are the angles and radians
presumably
is that right edges oh wait wait wait a
second what is this i don't even
understand what this is
so i think in polar plot these are
arrays
angles
i i don't know i never
okay so okay so this should just give
radially radial
error bars yeah i think so right in that
direction
it's more complicated if there's both a
theta and r which are both the rounds
in which case it should just give up you
know the the standard double
error bar type story yeah but tilt it
yeah i agree
right okay thank you for the bug
um okay should we
jump into wfr candidates yes
so this time there is a difference so in
the previous
iteration we sorted things by rank
but this time we have selected
similarly um like by areas
by the way people include pointing out
the bug is a serious problem for the
import function
for the dates we'll look at it see if we
i i
don't know whether we'll get it in for
12.3 if not we can at least provide a
fix in the function repository
something we haven't actually done but
with something we perfectly well could
do for something a point issue like this
so next i think that's for you okay
sorry please please go ahead
this is um yeah i was saying that these
36 functions are
all say language related so we have
tried this time to separate functions by
area
so in some other ielt meeting we will
have visualization functions and then
we will have okay all right
okay
symmetric difference
don't we have a smaller construct for
regions
i think so what is it called
don't remember but i think we have it
it's called region symmetric difference
there you go
so
yeah well
seems like a good thing to have
let's see what does it mean when you
have a
the union intersection of lists so
it's complement of union
so you can have any number of union of
the comp
of the pairwise complements
so it's ordered in some way
i mean think about union and all them
what do you mean by ordered
they all sort if that's what you mean
no i mean that the order of arguments
matters does it right oh um
actually that's a good point i had
forgotten no i
i don't think it matters true i don't
think it matters either
i thought
now the the related function that could
be also quite useful
is when you want to compare the two sets
and you want to know
which elements are in the first but not
in the second and which are in the
second but not in the first
oh yeah i that's my function in the
function repository
all compliments oh you have to write
yeah i called it all compliments
i have one of the best satirical
examples
they're somewhere
see it's all complements yeah this
operation i use a lot
i have two sets and i want to understand
their difference
so am i this is n sets here
so what am i seeing here i'm seeing the
things which are
unique to each one unique entirely to
each one so it's the it's the things
that are not in the union of all of them
the things
in each one that are not in no way i
mean i use this with just two sets
mostly but
it works with many this the description
could have been worded a little better
but it's the union minus the
intersection
for symmetric difference
isn't that only the case for exactly two
no i i think it's for more than two
judging from
because i thought the symmetric
difference for more than two was
the elements that are in an odd number
of the list
there there's different interpretations
of which that's
one that's viable i don't think that's
what was implemented though
i vaguely remember we had some back and
forth uh with george about this
and went with it as is
i have to look at the code though i mean
maybe you're right maybe that is what it
does
um okay so hold on i'm trying to
understand what this thing should be
called
so look symmetric difference seems well
defined
and presumably agrees with the way that
region symmetric difference works
yes so i oh oh no it doesn't
um there's there's a separate functional
category entry called multi-set
symmetric difference and that
corresponds with region symmetric
difference oh
for goodness sake what's going on so
multiset symmetric difference is the one
that counts
or it looks for the things that are in
an odd number of the lists
which is what region symmetric
difference does
so i guess i haven't figured out what oh
god the electric difference is doing yet
this seems like a mess let's go figure
this out okay
and i don't think if if region symmetric
difference is doing the even odd thing
there's no way that symmetric difference
can do something different
so if there's a different operation it's
a different name
and there's all complements thing
let's see
this is saying okay what this
is saying is um
unique to a to a list right
that's what it's saying it's something
that's unique to a list
right unique elements or something could
be the name
that's not terrible
right i used a lot to find diffs like if
i have a
history of some array
yeah maybe that's a better operation for
that right things are added and removed
from the array
seeing what changed at each time step
but it's not what changed in successive
steps it's what changed
well if you do like a moving map if you
do like a moving map of this thing
right i usually just use it with two
things and that's the application i use
it for best
but there are other applications then
it's not obvious that that having a
sublist because notice that
the symmetric difference here is of
their logs right
right it could be varrocks certainly and
then there's an application that i put
in here where
you're like you're for like meta
programming where you find
which options for one function are not
also used by another function
so you know how to parse out option
specs into different sub
tasks you know what i mean yeah i know
what you mean
i mean this does seem yeah
i think there's a little bit more to
both of these i think there's a little
bit more to
you know identifying pairwise unique
identifying even odd etc etc etc i think
there's several
and here's what i'd like to do can we
get it looked at what the image
processing analogs of these are
the region analogs etc and then come
back
to this make sense
yep
i mean what i do for this all the time
is first
slash at split
that's basically what the implementation
is for this
it doesn't seem like a bad function to
have
i mean it seems pretty clear what it's
doing
um
what let's see the sequence
hmm
what are you saying similar to what
overlaps does
are you saying that yeah
yeah this reminded me of of overlaps for
sequence
um cases etc why does it
why are you saying that um
because rather than having a separate
function
in sequence cases sequence cases takes
this overlaps functional
options sorry that controls whether you
look at neighbors etc
oh okay but but i understand but so is
this function
the overlaps of some other function
no it's it is if you have cases that are
going to return
lists that contain overlapping
elements then you can control whether
you want those additionally or not
so this is a bit like in the operation
of delete duplicates
do you in the process look at neighbors
or
or yeah but it's do you only look at
neighbors
yeah i don't think i don't think we can
get to it by an overlaps
i mean we could get to it if we said
that delete duplicates
yes i'm not saying that it should be
overlapped the option
i'm saying that rather than a different
function it could be an option some
options
some options to delete duplicates
like adjacent only or something like
that
what else i mean
you know i suppose one could imagine
versions of delete duplicates that is
more like
uh a an outlier deletion
you could also have delete duplicates by
where the function
takes more than one argument
like a moving map oh yeah yeah
was the question of once you've deleted
a duplicate do you
look at it in comparison to the next or
do you look at the one before it
yeah in particular for the buy
i think you would always just look at
the original list but
that's like happy to be overruled
you can imagine like diddly duplicates
buy the list
same queue comma two
we're two saying how many things put in
the size of the
map right where where delete duplicates
by by default would have only one but
it's a little bit weird that it i see
would have to be a vera the same queue
would work because vera arg's thing
right right exactly duplicate spy does
seem quite useful
so if we had delete duplicates by we
have delete duplicates back
oh we do yeah does it does it take
multiple no it's just applied to each
element individually
so you can do like in associations
really
when you're comparing associations is
really useful because you say
you know hash of name
right okay so what you're proposing is
if dilute duplicates by
had you know had another argument so it
could you could say two comma same q for
example
right what will be the analog of what
what function is analogous to
the two it's like partition or something
by the way when are we going to set it
up so that partition has some kind of
string names
i mean moving map with the third
argument is a window spec
okay when are we going to set it up to
give
symbolic names like cyclic and so on for
partition
like that is there any good reason we
haven't done that
there's defining silence i'm thinking
what
that would mean
i mean typically you put numbers there
so that you specify some
offsets
i know and they're super hard to
understand and every time i look at this
you know it's kind of like you have to
repeat the list to make it cyclic and so
on
i'm totally fine with having these
strings if they uniquely identify
their corresponding numeric
version well i understand i understand
so there's a question of cyclic
where does it begin from and things
right
although often you don't really care you
just want something cyclic
now i admit that yeah i admit that this
you know you could be starting five six
so you could be starting whatever
i mean right now it takes me forever and
by the way the documentation is not very
clear on this
um you know how do you what's the
minimal way to make a cyclic thing here
paired with a cyclic with repetition of
elements but that's the padless
what about this
i mean doesn't it isn't the obvious
thing
well i okay i admit look
this is the thing i want all the time
these cyclic partition things
um and i do admit that it's not
completely obvious what this should be
so if you say one two comma one for
example
yeah right no so it's but the third
argument is about offsets
so it's going to repeat in the results
elements
so if we say two comma one it's going to
return four five five six
which is yes that's what we want here
what do you want is a result
four five six four
indeed yes indeed
i mean look there are two things we've
considered here one is a wrapper for
lists which indicates that they're
cyclic
right which i think we should still
consider
because i think they'll be useful in
part and many other places
i mean we could imagine a cyclic list
construct
you know well this would just work
yes but the partition
if we have a cyclic list it formally
will have infinite length
so how to partition it is not clear
that's a fair point
well i mean
yeah i understand especially if for
example the weird case would be
i have a non-commensurate number here
with relative to the length
so it's going to flip around you know
what i'm saying
yep hmm
i admit that's kind of complicated i i
do think this is worth thinking about
can we put this on a future agenda
cyclic list
and cyclic partition
maybe cyclic partition should be the um
yeah i agree it's not completely well
defined
okay delete addition duplicates seems
like a reasonable thing to have
is it obvious wait a minute which way
round
yes if they're duplicates i mean
duplicates by
gets more complicated because the
question where's the representative
but delete duplicates to delete
adjacent duplicates seems well defined
well you still have the question of did
i delete it already
or do i delete it after i've used it to
check its neighbor
what do you mean if if it's adjacent
duplicates
isn't it completely well defined it's
just the equivalent of first slash at
split
you know i mean if you keep deleting
suppose you have a b
c c c c d e don't you delete all of
those c's
about one no you leave one of them you
know this one
i mean i'm not one sorry you delete all
but one
because they were adjacent yes
what's the issue well the issue
is if you have something that's not
like in particular the bi case but this
can happen with numbers if they're not
transitive
the comparisons
you know same queue is not always what
will just delete duplicates do
god only knows well it has the same
issue it's got the same test
yeah got the same issue
i'm sure it does now that you mentioned
it
that's an interesting suggestion from
muhammad in our live stream please
support pre-subscript and plea
pre-superscript
boxes to support actuarial notation
and some boxes to support the actuarial
angle
i do not know those things
um do these things look like
oh wow
that's a good suggestion for some well
first of all for something
function repository i've just not i
didn't know about these things at all
um
duration actuarial note i mean look at
this um
okay well this looks like a terrific
function repository thing
i didn't know this stuff at all
good thing for us to have good thing for
me to know about i didn't know anything
about
this um
it's different to sue
um
okay well this seems like a good
suggestion
i there seems to be some kind of angle
hat thing which i'd not seen before
[Music]
um
yeah actuarial angle actuarial symbol
well let's make the suggestion
right i mean first step is let's get
them into a function repository
entry and i suspect i mean i think these
things are doable
in the front end but they may be kind of
complicated and then the question is
what is their representation
in you know directly in the language
but first step is is yeah well
what is it what do you have in mind that
would go into the function repository
that function that typesets some some
you know look clearly we need a way to
represent
this thing i don't know what that is
because i don't think because we don't
have direct
representation of actuarial constructs
right i just can't see how this would be
done without support from front end
oh because i'm assuming that all these
things can be done by various kinds of
you know adjacent boxes i would think so
okay maybe an overlay boxes and and um
uh you know adjustment boxes and so on
i think it probably would require
adjustment boxes
with a font measurement that's done
dynamically
it can probably be done there aren't a
ton of people who could do it
right this is very interesting i did not
know there was any such notation
well thank you for that all right anyway
that's
that's um a note for that
okay should we go on here um
one minor thing we have a duplicate free
queue
would that need an adjacent duplicate
for q
i don't think so where you can have an
overlaps
option
overlaps is going to be incomprehensible
the name is bad but but perhaps an
option with some other name
i think this function is you know look
you can't have every possible function
so
you know delete adjacent duplicates it's
very
clear what it means you know
adjacent duplicate frequent who cares
you know you you can
i just don't think it's important okay
all right shuffling so we have a bunch
of shuffling
stuff in the function repository and
we've already combined
a bunch of them into a sort of master
function just called shuffle
and the function repository in the
function repository that takes this
type of shuffle as a final argument
so we should consider these as a family
maybe we want them all broken up into
different functions no i don't think so
i mean i would i don't know what they're
used for exactly
i mean there are algorithms there are a
few algorithms i'm aware of that use
shuffle functions
what are they typically used for think i
saw the author of some of these on the
on the live stream oh yeah sandra is
there
commenting on the fact that these are
great functions they very nicely
look look at that nice talking oh yeah
his diagrams are amazing
um
but but tell me what these are used for
deck of cards i know that i mean i think
they used various algorithms
it might be used for experimental
designs
yes
you know we have been i would say
inadequate in terms of experimental
design
kinds of um you know obviously some
functions for experimental design that
would be useful
okay let's just look ahead here at i
don't we're not going to get too many
more of these
[Music]
this one i am partial to
because i seem to need it so often
or something like it
george on the livestream is talking
about the fischer yates shuffle
sounds very statistical that sounds like
an experimental design it sounds
sounds to me like something where
somebody will be doing
if i'm not mistaken both i'm let's see
if i'm
if i'm um
ah okay there's a commenter about ad
code completion being useful
oh boy there's a lot of different things
here
um
well it seems to me we've got more to
study about shuffles
there's a lot of interesting things here
okay
oh boy
um
fair enough look i think we're probably
um uh not going to achieve much more
right here today um
so uh
okay well should we should wrap up for
today
um and bring these back another time
okay we'll do that okay thanks to folks
here thanks to folks on the live stream
by the way i'm supposed to be doing
another live stream
about business and innovation in half an
hour um
but i have other things to do first so i
gotta run off